* Kreischen *
* Gestelltes Schluchzen *
That's not real! Das ist ...
- (Junge) Oh mein Gott!
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
* Kreischen *
Wow!
(Mädchen) Oh mein Gott!
* Kreischen *
Crazy.
* Lautes, hysterisches Kreischen *
Schreit alle mal so laut ihr könnt!
* Lautes, schrilles Kreischen *
* Jauchzer *
* Perlende Klänge *
# I see you.
* Elektronischer Remix *
* I keep watchin'.
* Perlende Klänge *
* Elektronischer Remix *
# I see you.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
* Elektronischer Remix *
* Perlende Klänge *
Man kann hier
eigentlich Bilder schiessen,
aber es geht gerade nicht.
Es geht nicht.
Ich mache dann halt immer so -
und dann halt gerade.
Wenn ich so mache,
habe ich halt ein Doppelkinn.
Wenn ich nach hinten gehe.
Wenn ich aber normal
nach vorne schaue, geht das gut.
Ich finde,
ein Bild muss perfekt sein.
Z.B. hier so ein wenig ...
Oder hier habe ich auch eine Beule.
Und hier habe ich eine Narbe.
Mittels einer App namens Facetune
kann ich alles wegmachen.
Und wieso lässt man das nicht?
Weil die Welt auf Instagram
perfekt ist
und alle perfekt aussehen.
Das perfekte Selfie.
Eben, jetzt ein wenig glätten.
Was glättest du hier?
- Diesen Ausschlag.
Also die Pickel?
- Ja, sozusagen.
Meine Augen
mache ich jeweils auch grüner.
Das ist aber Mogeln.
Ich weiss,
aber Instagram ist auch Betrug.
* Unverständliche Gespräche
im Video *
Sein Online-Ich
hat nur wenig mit seinem Alltag
als Migros-Lehrling gemein.
Im Kosmos der Sozialen Medien
ist Younes Model und Entertainer.
Zehntausende Fans,
vorwiegend weibliche,
folgen ihm auf Plattformen
wie Instagram, Snapchat oder TikTok.
Letzteres ist eine Playback-App,
auf der hauptsächlich Teenies
ihre Lippen
synchron zu einem Song bewegen.
* Deutscher Rap:
"Sonnenbrille" von Loredana Zefi *
# ... ja, sie sagen zu mir: "Stopp!"
# Doch mein Lächeln zu charmant,
nein, ich mach' mir da keinen Kopf.
* Sanfte Ballade:
"Changes" con XXXTentacion *
# You're changing, I can't stand it.
# My heart can't take this damage.
* Schnelles Weiterspulen
von Popmusik *
Ich mach es halt auch,
um Unterhaltung zu haben.
Denn wenn ich morgens aufstehe,
möchte ich mich noch nicht bewegen -
die Fernbedienung liegt zu weit weg,
das Handy jedoch hier.
Ich nehme es
und checke kurz alles ab.
Manchmal
spiele ich auch ein Game oder so.
Aber ...
meistens ist es schon Sucht.
Denn wenn ich mal auf Instagram bin,
dann nicht nur so 10 Min.
bzw. 2 Min.
Z.T. bin ich dann 30 Min.
oder 1 Std. auf Instagram.
Denn ich sehe immer wieder etwas,
das ich mir ansehen will.
Ich sehe immer wieder was Spannendes
oder: "Welche Person ist das?"
Dann geh ich da drauf und da.
Plötzlich war ich 1 Std. am Handy
und stehe um 12 Uhr auf.
* Hip-Hop-Musik, unterschiedliche
Stimmen, elektronische Geräusche *
* Push-Geräusche *
Was kommt hier immer rein?
- Fans. Auf Snapchat.
"OMG, Younes, ich liebe dich.
Bleib so, wie du bist."
Merci. Ich schreibe denen
jeweils zurück, genau.
Ich schreibe: "Hey, merci vielmals."
Du erhältst immer viele Herzen.
- Immer Herzen.
Ich kann nicht ohne Social Media.
Es ist wie einer, der raucht:
Man kann nicht aufhören.
Eine Sucht?
- Eine Sucht, genau.
Wonach bist du süchtig?
Danach, mich
in der Öffentlichkeit zu zeigen.
Danach,
mein Leben zu veröffentlichen,
damit die Leute sehen,
was ich privat und auch sonst mache.
Weil es sie interessiert,
was ich mache. Und ...
Aber was gibt es dir?
- Mir? - Ja.
Ein gutes Gefühl.
- Wieso?
Weil die Leute
an mir interessiert sind. Genau.
Und ...
Es kann sein,
dass ich bis zu 1 Std. brauche.
Es kommt ganz drauf an.
Manchmal brauche ich länger,
weil ich mehr Lidschatten auftrage.
Ich schminke mich etwas stärker,
damit es auf den Bildern
besser aussieht.
Ja.
Nur damit ich's gesagt habe:
Meine Augenbrauen
sehen anfangs schlimm aus.
Wenn ich fertig bin,
sehen sie besser aus.
Es hat auch
was mit Instagram zu tun.
Man sieht, wie sich alle schön
schminken, und versucht es auch.
* Rap-Musik:
"Taste" von Tyga feat. Offset *
Sie sieht einfach megagut aus.
- Hier schaust du die Augenbrauen ab?
Ja, so in etwa.
Sie sehen ähnlich aus, oder?
Gott, was hat mein Bruder gemacht?
Warte, ich muss kurz ...
Die Sucht nach Likes treibt ihn an:
Younes verbringt viel Zeit damit,
sich in allen Lebenslagen
selber zu fotografieren
oder sich fotografieren zu lassen.
* Klickgeräusche der Handykamera *
Woah, chill! Asja!
* Lachen *
Seine beste Freundin hat sich längst
an Younes Selfiemanie gewöhnt.
Lol.
* Sie lacht. *
Also, ist gut?
- Okay.
Es ist verdammt heiss.
- Ja. Ich fühle dich.
Warum braucht er deiner Meinung nach
so viel Anerkennung?
Sei ehrlich!
- Ja ... weil ...
Weil er vielleicht nicht immer
100%ige Aufmerksamkeit erhalten hat.
Er wurde früher gemobbt.
Genau.
Ich denke, dass die Leute ...
"Ich gefalle den Leuten,
ich bin jemand."
"Ich bin cool,
man spricht über mich."
Das ist halt einfach das,
was ihm Sicherheit gibt.
Ja.
- Hat sie recht?
Ja, sie hat recht.
* Handygeräusche *
Oh Gott, es ist so heiss.
* Asja lacht. *
* Push-Ton *
Perfekt.
- Ist gut?
Ja.
- Bist du zufrieden?
Ja, ich bin zufrieden.
- Sehr gut.
Was ist schön an diesem Bild?
Sein arroganter Blick:
"Ich bin jemand."
Ja.
- "Ich bin jemand."
Und du bearbeitest es hier draussen?
- Ja.
Was bearbeitest du denn jetzt?
Ich mache meinen Oberkörper
etwas schmaler.
Wirklich? Das geht?
- Ja. Ja, das geht.
Es geht wirklich.
- Alles geht.
Was gefällt dir nicht
an deinem Oberkörper?
Ich weiss es auch nicht.
Kannst du ...
Hältst du dich für zu dick?
- Manchmal.
Das ist jetzt Kylie Jenner.
Ich fände es schon schön, wenn ich
wie Kylie Jenner aussehen würde.
Das wäre toll, aber ...
Das sind einfach Vorbilder.
Selfie-Queen Kylie Jenner
hat es vom TV-Sternchen
zur Multimillionärin geschafft.
Dank zielstrebiger Vermarktung
ihres Lebens
und ihrer eigenen Beautyprodukte
in den sozialen Medien.
Ich kann auch ... Soll ich's zeigen?
Ich habe eine ganze Schublade voll
mit Make-up von ihr.
D.h., sie hat bei dir erreicht,
was sie will: Du hast es gekauft.
Und noch mehr. Diese Paletten
ab hier sind von Kylie Jenner.
Wie viel hast du dafür ausgegeben?
- Das waren über 3'000 Fr.
Wie finanzierst du es?
Auf gut Deutsch gesagt:
Meine Mutter bezahlt es.
Gerade Kylie Jenner ist ja nicht nur
so schön, weil sie sich gut schminkt.
Sie hat auch nachgeholfen.
Ja, sie hat nachgeholfen.
Es stört mich nicht.
Ich hab auch schon nachgeholfen.
Was genau?
- Die Lippen und meine Nase.
Ich finde, wenn man sich dann wohler
fühlt, soll man es doch machen.
Ich finde, es sieht auch gut aus.
- Aber sie sollte ein Vorbild sein.
Ist es nicht die falsche Botschaft
an junge Frauen?
Für andere
kommt es vielleicht so rüber,
aber für mich kommt es halt so ...
Sie macht das, weil es ihr gefällt
und sie sich so besser fühlt.
Ich mache es auch,
weil ich mich so wohler fühle
und mir dann besser gefalle.
* Perlende Klänge *
* Push-Klänge *
Auch Michelle postet fortwährend
Fotos und Videos von sich.
Auf dem Bildernetzwerk Instagram
hat sie 5'000 sog. Followers,
also Abonnenten,
die ihrem Profil folgen.
Auf der Teenieplattform TikTok
sind es sogar 72'000.
* Perlende Klänge *
Ich mache noch kurz eine Snap-Story.
- Machen wir.
Aber mit Effekt. Okay.
Hi, guys.
- Hello, wir sind da.
Wohin gehen wir?
- Jahrmarkt.
Kommt alle an den Jahrmarkt.
Wir sehen uns, bitches.
- Bis gleich.
Warum macht ihr das?
Wie?
- Warum macht ihr das?
Wir sagen immer,
wohin wir gehen oder was wir tun.
Warum?
- Es ist einfach so ein Tick.
Wie gesagt, man erzählt immer,
wo man ist und was man macht.
Genau.
- Ja.
Machen wir ... Sorry, aber ...
Das gibt eine Instagram-Story.
Was machst du? Ein Video?
Ich bin hier mit Younes.
- Hi. Mit You-nes.
Hey, You-nes.
(Frau) Vorbilder.
Schöne Augen.
Das hier ist ein Influencer.
Weiss jemand,
was ein Influencer ist?
Menschen, die nicht arbeiten, son-
dern durchs Internet Geld verdienen.
Er macht auch Fotos von sich.
Und davon, was er macht.
- Genau.
Er postet sie dann
und kriegt Likes dafür.
Und für jedes Like erhält er Geld.
Genau. Wenn jemand sehr viele Likes
hat, wissen junge Menschen heute,
dass man damit Geld verdienen kann.
Der Umgang mit sozialen Medien
als Thema im Unterricht.
Ziel ist die Sensibilisierung
der Schülerinnen und Schüler
für manipulierte Bilder
und versteckte Werbebotschaften.
Häufig gehen Social-Media-Grössen
Kooperationen ein
und werden gesponsert.
Auch Younes.
Zwar kann er seinen Lebensunterhalt
nicht mit dem Einkommen
als Online-Star bestreiten,
aber er bekommt Markenklamotten
sowie Accessoires kostenlos gestellt.
Im Wissen, dass sein Style
von den Kids kopiert wird.
Was ist das Schöne
oder Tolle an Younes,
dass du ihm folgst und ihn likest?
Keine Ahnung,
das mache ich automatisch.
Automatisch? Schaut man nicht mal?
Man liked einfach?
Ja?
- Ja.
Das ...
Das würde ich liken, weil ich
seinen Pulli und seine Brille mag.
Und ich habe dieselbe Tasche,
einfach in Blau.
Blau-Schwarz.
- In echt?
Es ist ja eine teure Tasche.
Also ... original?
- Ja.
Nein, meine ist fake.
Denn die krieg ich noch nicht.
Du hast dieselbe?
Ich habe dieselbe,
aber meine ist kaputt gegangen.
Ja.
Ich fühle mich einfach schöner
mit dieser Tasche.
Und ich kann halt Sachen reinmachen.
Und ... ja ...
Weil Younes und andere Stars diese
Tasche haben, wie ich gesehen habe,
möchte ich sie auch haben.
* Dumpfe Popmusikklänge,
Stimmengewirr *
So. Ist gut? So ist gut.
Merci.
- Tschüss zusammen.
Hallo.
Younes' Popularität im virtuellen
wirkt sich auch
auf sein reales Leben aus.
Wo er auftaucht,
zücken die Fans das Handy.
Hat's geklappt?
- Ja.
Danke.
- Bitte. Tschüss.
Was machst du jetzt mit diesem Bild?
Ist stelle es auf Instagram.
Und schicke es meinen Freundinnen.
Es könnte nicht besser sein.
Warum ist es so cool,
Younes zu treffen?
Ich weiss nicht.
- Er ist halt voll bekannt.
Ja.
Oh mein Gott!
* Kreischen *
Ich kotze!
Oh mein Gott!
Viele Follower und Klicks auf TikTok
machten aus Younes vor zwei Jahren
ein nationales Teenie-Idol.
Darf ich auch mal?
Darf ich ein Foto mit dir machen?
Und sie möchte auch eines.
Autogramme waren gestern,
heute macht man Selfies.
Darf ich dir
einen Kuss auf die Wange geben?
* Hysterisches Kreischen *
* Stimmengewirr *
Wie ist das jetzt für dich?
Ähm ... es ist ... nice.
Aber mit der Zeit
wird es mir schon zu viel.
Wird es dir dennoch zu viel?
- Ja, irgendwann schon.
Aber es ist das, was ich wollte.
Ja ... Man muss sich daran gewöhnen.
Jahrmarkt?
- Ja.
Was für ein Lied ist es?
Du bist ja der totale Mädchenschwarm.
- Ja.
Wissen deine Fans,
dass du schwul bist?
Ähm ... über dieses Thema
möchte ich lieber nicht sprechen.
Ich finde einfach, meine sexuelle
Orientierung ist Privatsache.
Was sagst du dazu?
Ich finde, man sollte zu dem stehen,
was man ist.
Ähm ... und ... ja.
Ja.
Mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Zu dem stehen, was man ist, ja.
Ich stehe auch dazu,
aber ich möchte nicht ...
Es ist einfach Privatsache.
Ich möchte nicht darüber reden.
Wirklich nicht.
* Reggeaton-Song:
"Buena Vida Mala Fama" *
* von Diego Villacis DVM
feat. Luandy & Crish Ramirez, Defab *
* Deutscher Rap:
"Tamam Tamam" von Summer Cem *
* Rhythmischer Ragga-Song *
Warum schaut ihr euch das an?
Was bringt es euch?
Wenn mir langweilig ist, gehe ich
auf TikTok und sehe es mir an.
Dann klickt man halt drauf
und denkt: "Wow, wie schön!"
Dann möchte man auch dasselbe tun.
* R'n'B-Remix:
"Survivor" von Destiniy's Child *
Dann ist man auch stolz auf sich und
denkt: "Wow, das hab ich gemacht."
Aber dann möchte man
auch Likes haben, oder? - Ja.
Wenn ich versuche ... Meine Eltern
sagten, ich sei auch so schön.
Wenn ich aber versuche, schön
auszusehen, und dieses Video drehe,
ich aber dennoch wenige Likes
kriege, frage ich mich,
warum irgendein Mädchen
50 Likes erhält und ....
Keine Ahnung, ich gebe mir Mühe,
kriege aber dennoch nur 20 Likes.
Ja.
- Likes sind etwas Tolles.
Denn man hat ja Arbeit reingesteckt
und dann sieht man,
dass es auch anderen gefällt.
Ich schaue halt, wie die Person mit
mehr Likes die Videos gemacht hat.
Oder wenn sie halt 50 Likes hat,
frage ich sie,
wie sie es gemacht hat.
Und kopierst du es dann?
- Ja.
Denn man möchte gleich viele Likes?
* Perlende Klänge *
Sie geben sich Mühe, haben Ideen.
Ja.
- Fantasie, alles.
Der Rest ist ...
Herzen fliegen Younes
nicht nur in Form von Likes zu.
Selbst seine Mutter ist überrascht,
wie viele Fans
für ihren Sohn schwärmen.
Herzchen
und alle sind in ihn verliebt.
Sie schreiben ja Bücher.
Warum wird er so geliebt?
Haben Sie eine Erklärung dafür?
Weil ich ihn auch so liebe.
Nein. Ich weiss nicht,
weil er es wohl gut macht.
Aber was macht er gut?
Seine Sympathie,
er hat Ausstrahlung.
Ich bringe mich halt gut rüber.
- Ja?
Ja.
- Du verkaufst dich also gut?
Genau. Sagen wir,
ich verkaufe mich gut.
Obwohl so ...
Es gibt auch Hochs und Tiefs.
Immer so.
- Ist er nicht immer nur glücklich?
Nein, man kann nicht
immer glücklich sein.
Er hat also auch eine andere
Seite, ist nicht nur der Sonnyboy?
Nein, nicht nur der Sonnyboy.
- Aber die Seite zeige ich nicht.
Was ist das für eine Seite?
Ich hab manchmal so meine Tage.
- Was für Tage sind das?
Traurige oder ...
- Wenn mir alles zu viel wird.
Dann ... Mit Social Media und so ...
Das kommt vor.
Ziehst du dich dann zurück?
Nicht zurückziehen,
ich poste dann lange nichts mehr.
Aber dann poste ich
trotzdem wieder was.
Younes, der ohne Vater aufwuchs, lebt
heute gemeinsam mit seiner Mutter,
ihrem neuen Mann
und dem kleinen Halbbruder zusammen.
Was fehlt ihm,
das er dann damit füllt?
Mit diesen Likes.
- Eine gewisse Liebe, denke ich.
Ja? Von wem?
Sehr wahrscheinlich auch vom Vater.
Und Sie haben ihm immer ...
- Ich habe alles versucht.
Vielleicht gab ich ihm zu viel.
Ich habe alles ... also alles ...
- Ja.
An Liebe und auch Anerkennung?
- Liebe, Anerkennung und ...
Ich habe mehr Liebe erfahren
durch Sachen -
Geld, einfach materielle Dinge.
Also eben Geld und das ...
Ich hab wirklich alles bekommen,
was ich haben wollte.
Und ...
- Von wem? Von Ihnen?
Von meiner Mutter.
- Von der Mutter?
Hättest du aber
lieber was anderes gehabt?
Ich denke schon.
- Vielleicht.
Aber ich war schon glücklich
mit den Sachen.
Ich war wahrscheinlich zu jung.
- Waren Sie nicht da?
Ich arbeitete viel, 13 Std. am Tag.
Ich war immer bei der Arbeit.
Deshalb ... Ich sah ihn, wenn ...
... er aufwachte
und wenn er zu Bett ging.
Und ich ging arbeiten,
da ich ihn ja alleine ...
... aufgezogen habe.
- Aufgezogen und erzogen?
Und erzogen, sozusagen.
Dann habe ich ihm vielleicht ...
Ich hatte mehr Stress als ...
... Zeit für ihn zu nehmen, richtig,
wie ich mir jetzt
für Cristian Zeit nehme.
Ich male mehr mit ihm,
bastle, was auch immer.
Du sagtest, du wurdest gemobbt.
Ja. Ich war fett. Ziemlich fett.
Er schämte sich.
Für seinen Körper.
- Ich war wirklich so.
Mh ...
- Doch!
Das ist übertrieben.
- Doch.
Ich wog mit zwölf irgendwie ...
- Er schämte sich.
... 75 kg oder so. Mit zwölf.
Und ... ja.
Und wie viel wiegst du jetzt?
- 56.
Mein Aussehen
ist halt wirklich alles für mich.
Ja.
- Ja.
* Melodiöser Hip-Hop:
"Hope" von XXXTentacion *
Zelebrieren des eigenen Ichs:
Wie Younes sucht auch Michelle
in den Sozialen Medien
nach Selbstbestätigung.
Wer Likes und Followers jagt, muss
aus der Bilderflut herausstechen.
Bewährtes Mittel: aufreizende Posen.
Und so sieht dich eigentlich
die ganze Welt? Im Bikini? - Ja.
Im Freibad sehen sie mich
auch im Bikini, also ...
Es macht keinen Unterschied,
ob auf Instagram oder im Freibad.
Man kann auch ins Freibad
und mich im Bikini sehen.
Ich muss einfach nicht so ...
Ich poste nicht so ...
"Oh, mein Arsch, oh, meine Möpse"
und dies und das.
Ich poste einfach so. Ich finde
auch, dass es gut aussieht.
Aber nicht wegen sex sells.
Ich finde, es sieht ...
Es hat nichts damit zu tun, dass man
weiss ... - Ich finde es weiblich.
Es kommen Dinge wie "Du Drecks-
schlampe", "Du Drecksfotze" oder so.
Was habe ich denen angetan?
Ich stelle Fotos rein, same as you.
Und deshalb ... lässt du
solche Sachen gegen mich raus?
Ich zeige mal,
was ich hier tätowiert habe.
Da steht:
"You know my name, not my story".
Weil so viele Menschen urteilen, oh-
ne zu wissen, wer du wirklich bist.
Du könntest dich
doch ganz verabschieden?
Ich will jetzt nicht aufhören.
Das wäre auch langweilig.
Ich brauche mein Handy.
Und ich brauche etwas drauf, damit
ich etwas am Handy machen kann.
Deswegen ...
würde ich es nicht löschen.
Ich brauche das. Für meine Seele.
* Klicken der Handykamera *
Auch Chiara präsentiert sich
auf ihrem Instagram-Account
öffentlich im Bikini.
Worauf schaust du?
Hm ... Zum Einen ...
ob ich einen flachen Bauch habe.
Eigentlich bin ich dafür,
dass man nicht nicht denkt,
dass man immer
einen flachen Bauch haben muss.
Weil alle Fitnessmodels und so
rüberbringen, dass das schön ist
und man nur schön ist,
wenn man einen flachen Bauch hat.
Aber du achtest trotzdem drauf?
- Ja.
Es ist ... irgendwie völlig ...
Es macht eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Aber irgendwie kommt das einfach gut
an bei den Leuten, das weiss ich.
Du fotografierst dich
häufig seitlich.
Eigentlich fast nur seitlich.
Ich habe gar keine Fotos von vorne.
Wieso nur seitlich?
- Ich fühle mich wohler.
Und ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich so besser aussehe.
Und dafür sieht man den Po besser?
Das auch, aber ...
Ja, es ist schon auch so.
Man kriegt halt z.T. mehr Likes,
wenn man das macht,
das ist heutzutage einfach so.
Nach dem Vorbild
ihrer Instagram-Idole
will Michelle ihre Lippen
erneut aufspritzen lassen.
Der Eingriff ist mit der Unterschrift
der Eltern ab 16 Jahren erlaubt.
Die 350 Fr. teure Lippenvergrösserung
ist für Michelle gratis.
Als Gegenleistung macht die Schülerin
auf ihren Social-Media-Accounts
Werbung für die Beautyklinik.
Hello!
- Hallo.
Schön, dich wieder zu sehen.
- Gleichfalls. Wie geht's?
Gut, bald habe ich Ferien. Dir?
- Ich beginne bald die Lehre.
Wann denn?
- Ähm ... am zweiten. In zwei Tagen.
Okay. Freust du dich?
- Es geht. Habe etwas Angst.
Wenigstens beginnst du mit
super Lippen. - Das ist immer gut.
Was bringt sie Ihnen jetzt?
- Extrem viel.
Früher nannten wir es im Marketing
Mund-zu-Mund-Propaganda,
heutzutage sind es die Influencer.
D.h.: Spread the word. Sie erzählt
es ihren Kolleginnen, teilt es.
Diese erzählen es dann
auch wieder weiter.
Aber ist sie nicht etwas jung?
- Jung?
Und auch ihre Follower.
- Es ist halt Generation Instagram.
Es ist Kylie Jenner.
Es ist ein neuer Trend.
Ich denke, es gibt kein "zu jung",
denn es ist auch wieder reversible.
Wenn sie das macht und es bereut -
in sechs Monaten ist's eh raus.
Es ist nicht wie eine Brust-
vergrösserung, die für immer bleibt.
Zudem
ist es ein natürliches Produkt,
das sich abbaut
und keine Schäden hinterlässt.
Bei ihr jetzt nicht.
Aber das Geld wäre weg.
Das Geld wäre weg -
aber es wäre eine Erfahrung mehr.
* Frau Lüönd lacht. *
Hier ist noch ein bisschen drin,
hier in den Seiten gar nichts mehr.
Du kannst es gleich selbst spüren.
Hier auch nicht mehr.
Aber es ist normal,
dass an den Seiten nichts ist,
denn da spritze ich auch nicht viel.
Schöne Beisserchen, was?
Kannst du schauen,
dass man das schön sieht?
Ich weiss, was du meinst.
Soll ich dir ein Bild zeigen?
Hier sieht man es.
Sie hat voll die perfekten Lippen.
Ja, ja,
das ist ja das, was ich meinte.
Einfach
ein bisschen mehr ... Kontur.
Aber das würde nicht zu dir passen.
Ihr Herz ist weiter auseinander,
darum kann man das so schön betonen.
Okay.
- Das hast du nicht. Guck mal!
Hier im Spiegel,
musst nicht ins Handy schauen.
* Klicken der Handykamera *
So. Ich beginne
an diesem Mundwinkel, wie immer.
Gehe mehrmals rein,
bis oben in dein Herz.
Mach mal den Mund etwas auf.
Und schön so bleiben!
Tief Luft holen! Und es geht los.
Ich spüre nichts.
- Den Mund schön auflassen.
* Push-Ton *
Mund zu.
Und dann schau mal.
Und, wie gefällt's dir?
- Perfekt.
Zufrieden. - Jetzt ist es
natürlich noch geschwollen.
* Perlende Klänge, Vibration *
* Michelle lacht. *
Seit fünf Jahren
ist Chiara auf Instagram aktiv,
zeigt öffentlich
die Veränderung ihres Körpers
von der
nur 25 kg leichten Magersüchtigen
zur durchtrainierten Sportlerin.
Mit den Vorher-nachher-Bildern
will Chiara zeigen,
dass es
einen Weg aus der Krankheit gibt.
Doch die Plattform hilft auch ihr.
Über 53'000 Instagram-Nutzer
folgen ihr,
schicken virtuelle Herzchen
und Zuspruch.
Pro Bild bekommt die Studentin
zwischen 1'500 und 4'000 Likes.
Eigentlich ist es nur eine
Scheinwelt, aber es freut trotzdem.
Doch.
Und hast du eine Erklärung dafür,
warum das bei dir so ist?
Die Erklärung ist vielleicht,
dass ich wenig Selbstvertrauen habe.
Ich bin normalerweise sehr zurück-
haltend. Aber auf Instagram nicht.
Ich habe mich überwunden, es zu ma-
chen, weil ich anderen helfen kann.
Aber ich bin selbstkritisch und habe
wenig Wertschätzung mir gegenüber.
Deshalb tut es mir gut, wenn ich
positive Kommentare bekomme. Ja.
Likes fürs Aussehen.
Der Körperkult im Internet
birgt Gefahren.
"Je schlanker, desto erfolgreicher"
lautet die Botschaft
zahlreicher Posts,
die junge Frauen und Mädchen
zum Abnehmen und Hungern animieren.
Mit fatalen Folgen.
Anorexie ist ja letztlich
eigentlich Selbstmord.
Aber es ist die Bestätigung,
dass man etwas schafft,
was andere nicht schaffen.
Z.T. ist es auch Anerkennung.
Anorexie ist letztlich auch eine ...
... ein Wettbewerb,
wer dünner oder kranker ist.
Es war indirekt Selbstzerstörung.
Ich konnte mich selbst
und bestimmte Dinge in meinem Leben
nicht akzeptieren.
Durch den Verzicht aufs Essen
und das Abnehmen ...
Man ...
... verschwindet langsam.
Und ich glaube, das war mein Ziel.
Langsam immer mehr zu verschwinden,
bis ich nicht mehr hier bin.
Nahrung hat für Chiara mittlerweile
eine neue Bedeutung bekommen.
Auf Instagram postet die 21-Jährige
Rezepte und Bilder ihrer Gerichte.
Food-Fotos sind für sie
weit mehr als nur ein Trend.
Als Magersüchtige fotografierte sie
jede ihrer Mahlzeiten
und stellte diese ins Netz.
Viel, nicht?
- Ja, ziemlich viele.
Das habe ich schon
seit drei, vier Jahren.
Deshalb.
* Chiara schnalzt. *
Wie viele sind es?
Ähm, Bilder?
- Ja.
Ähm, ich weiss es nicht genau,
aber sicher 2'000-3'000.
Die genaue Zahl weiss ich nicht.
Hier hat es angefangen.
2013.
Also doch schon vor fünf Jahren.
Also einen halbe Apfel?
Ja, der Rest ... Einen halben ass
ich so, der Rest kam ins Joghurt.
Das war mein Frühstück.
Und das war mein Pausenbrot.
Mittagessen, Zvieri ...
Und zum Abendessen ...
habe ich Bulgur mit Spargeln
und dann noch
Cracker und Weetabix gegessen.
Ganz zu Beginn von Instagram
fotografierte ich alles.
Ich wollte zeigen, dass ich esse.
Mit der Zeit konnte ich gar nicht
essen, wenn ich es nicht postete.
Es war wie:
"Gut, die anderen haben gesehen,
dass ich gegessen habe, dann kann
ich es auch essen." Dann ass ich es.
Aber wenn ich etwas esse, das andere
nicht sahen, darf ich's nicht essen.
Es ist so: Wenn es niemand sähe,
muss ich auch nicht essen.
* Klicken der Handykamera *
* Push-Töne *
* Push-Ton *
Hoi, Michelle!
- Hallo, Michelle!
(Michelle) Guten Tag. Hoi!
- Hallo? Hallo?
Der kommt zuerst dran.
- Der Bubele.
Der freut sich am meisten,
mich zu sehen.
Hoi! Wie war's?
Ich sage nichts.
Daisy Duck, was?
Hallo, Michelle.
- Hallo, Oma.
Wie geht's?
- Gut, danke.
Das fragen wir dich.
- Wie geht's dir?
Es war wieder Tortur.
Tortur? Wegen? Hat's wehgetan?
- Was hast du denn gemacht?
Ne, ich habe alles betäubt bekommen.
Und jetzt bist du erst mal fertig?
- Nein, ich muss jeden Monat gehen.
Jeden Monat?
- Ja.
Wieso?
- Sonst geht es immer wieder weg.
Das muss nicht ... - Natur
ist schon auch schön, weisst du?
Müssen wir jetzt darüber reden?
Ich höre nur Kritik, nichts Gutes.
Bist du jetzt enttäuscht?
- Ja. - Wieso?
Ich dachte, es komme mal was Posi-
tives, aber es kommt nur Negatives.
Das stimmt nicht.
- Doch.
(Oma) Das finde ich nicht.
- Ich finde es schön, wenn du ...
Wenn es noch zurückgeht, ist ja gut.
- Dann ist gut.
Du gehst nachher in die Schule usw.
Das musst du dann
schon ertragen können.
Aber wenn's zurückgeht,
ist gut, Michelle.
Sie mussten ja Ihre Erlaubnis geben.
- Ja.
Gleichwohl merke ich ...
Sie würde es sowieso machen,
weil es ihr so gefällt.
Mit 18 wird sie es dann machen,
weil ...
Ich bin vielleicht weniger
der Typ dafür, aber ...
Ja, und ...
Ich habe ein wenig gelesen
über Hylaron, oder wie es heisst.
Das wird sich auch abbauen, das geht
wieder etwas zurück. Von daher ...
Ich habe meine Enkelin
unwahrscheinlich gern.
Ich finde sie
ein bildhübsches Mädchen.
Und das ist immer das ...
Dass ich das nicht ganz ...
Das begreife ich nicht ganz.
Weil sie immer denkt,
sie sei nicht so schön.
Sonst würde sie es ja nicht machen.
Auch ungeschminkt
bist du sehr schön.
(Oma) Ja, sehr schön. Sehr schön.
* Michelle seufzt. *
Ein durchtrainiertes Hinterteil
liegt -
dank Instagram und Co. - im Trend.
Auch bei Chiara.
Der Lohn für das Hardcore-Training:
Extra-Likes für die Kehrseite.
Das Phänomen der selbstfotografierten
Hintern hat einen Namen: Belfie.
Eine Kombination aus dem Wort Butt,
zu Deutsch Po, und Selfie.
Das ist die Belfie-Queen.
Sie sagt, sie habe es erfunden.
Was hat sie erfunden?
- Sie habe mit den Belfies begonnen.
Also den Po in Szene setzen?
- Mhm.
Es ist einfach
so richtig gehypt heutzutage.
Nicht mehr wirklich die Oberweite,
wie früher.
Heute ist es eher das Hinterteil.
Man sieht es dauernd,
und wenn man es dauernd sieht ...
... geht das ... wird das
wie in den Kopf geschweisst.
Und dann ... ja.
- Bei dir auch?
Wenn du ehrlich bist, hat dich das
auch ... - Ja, logisch. Es ist ...
... beeinflusst?
- Ja, eigentlich schon.
Gab es eine Suchtverlagerung
von der Magersucht zur Sportsucht?
Ja, eben ...
Jahrelang war es eher eine Sucht.
Ich hatte meine Routine,
die ich immer durchzog.
Machte ich es mal nicht,
fühlte ich mich ziemlich schlecht.
Aber mittlerweile
ist es ganz anders.
Es ist kein Müssen.
Aber ich mag Bewegung.
* Klicken der Handykamera *
Eine Woche nachdem Michelle
sich die Lippen machen liess,
sind nun die Haare dran.
Bist du jetzt zufrieden
mit deinen Lippen?
Ja, ich finde,
sie sind perfekt geworden.
Klar möchte ich sie mir
noch etwas grösser und so aufbauen.
Aber sie sind mega natürlich
und mir gefällt das Ergebnis.
Auch in der Schule sagten viele,
ich hätte megaschöne Lippen und so.
Sie haben gar nicht gecheckt,
dass sie gemacht sind,
weil sie so natürlich sind.
- Und hast du was gesagt?
Ich sagte ihnen, dass sie gemacht
sind, und sie schauten verdutzt.
"Was, echt jetzt?" Ja.
Weil die künstlichen Haarsträhnen
gelitten haben,
lässt Michelle sie herausnehmen.
Wehmütig.
Die blonde Mähne
hat ihr stets viele Likes beschert.
Ein Video brachte es sogar
auf 107'000 Herzchen.
Dieses bekam die meisten Klicks.
(Coiffeuse) Der ist geil.
- Gell, der ist cool?
* Gospelmusik im Video *
Ja.
- Der ist wirklich gut.
Der Haarschwung, der jetzt kommt,
sieht am besten aus.
Brauchbar? - Nein. Ich muss
auf der anderen Seite stehen.
Wieso? - Keine Ahnung,
es ist meine bessere Seite.
Das geht nicht. - Dann halte mit der
anderen Hand. Oder ich fotografiere.
Die anderen sind schon okay.
- Nein. Das Licht ist nicht gut.
Oh nein.
- Nein, es gefällt mir nicht.
Bei Fotos ist entweder sein
oder mein Kopf abgeschnitten.
Das ist ziemlich mühsam.
Darf ich fragen, wieso du
die Bilder von euch beiden postest?
Ja. Weil ich ihn gern habe.
Nein, keine Ahnung. Ja.
Das will man allen mitteilen?
Du kannst ihn auch gern haben,
ohne es allen zu zeigen.
Ich bin relativ offen
und zeige auch was von meinem Leben.
Ich finde,
das muss ich nicht verstecken.
Fotos mit ihm zusammen
kommen auch immer gut an.
Ich habe nicht viele,
aber sie kommen immer gut an.
Sie werden geliked?
- Ja, das schon.
Und woran liegt das wohl? - Das
wissen wir wahrscheinlich nicht.
Dass es sozusagen Abwechslung ist,
dass auch ab und zu ...
Was anderes, und es ist süss.
- ... eine andere Person drauf ist.
Hm?
- Dass es süss ist.
Dreh dich ein bisschen.
Oder wie willst du?
Sag was!
- Egal.
Okay.
Dann schau aber auch!
- Es windet.
* Push-Ton *
Wir nehmen das von vorher.
(Coiffeuse)
Wie läuft's mit deinem Schatzi?
Schlechtes Thema. Ganz schlecht.
- Okay.
Er hat gestern Schluss gemacht.
- Ui.
Mhm. Deswegen ...
Du oder er?
- Er.
Schon wieder. - Egal,
ich finde einen neuen, besseren.
Immer positiv denken, nicht?
- Ja.
Dann kommst du auch weiter im Leben.
Es gibt immer einen Besseren
als ihn, das weiss ich.
Ihr wart aber lange zusammen.
- Fast zwei Jahre.
Dein Ex hat...
- Der wird's schon noch erleben.
Ist das dein Ex?
- Ja, dem gebe ich alles.
Ich habe viel zur Story hinzugefügt.
Bilder, die ich schon gemacht habe.
Auch, um ihn zu provozieren.
Bilder, auf denen ich gut aussehe.
Z.B. so.
Uiuiui!
- Mit hohen Schuhen und so.
Hohe Schuhe, rückenfrei ...
- Ja, das provoziert.
... Popo zeigen.
Dieses.
Ich weiss genau,
wie es ihn provoziert.
Ich weiss genau, wie es ihn nervt.
Ich weiss es ganz genau.
Oder das habe ich gepostet.
- Oh.
Einer von Instagram,
der mir mega gefällt.
* Melodiöser Hip-Hop im Video *
Ja.
- Du bist mir eine!
Ich weiss genau,
dass ich ihn so provozieren kann.
Ich merke ja eigentlich ...
Er macht Schluss mit mir,
aber ich merke, dass es ihn stresst,
weil er dann
das Gleiche macht wie ich.
Was willst du
mit der Provokation bezwecken?
Also ...
Dass er merkt, was er verloren hat.
V.a. mal das. Denn er weiss ganz
genau: Er hat was Gutes verloren.
Ich möchte irgendwie auch bezwecken,
dass er zurückkommt und sagt:
"Ich vermisse dich so,
ich liebe dich!"
Hat er ja schon mal gemacht.
- Eben. Hat er schon mal gemacht.
Die, die sie mögen, sollen's tun.
- Ja.
* Dance-Musik: "One Kiss"
von Calvin Harris & Dua Lipa *
# One kiss is all it takes,
fall in love with me, possibilities.
(Mädchen) Na los!
- Er kennt den Text nicht.
Das ist sweet. Geil!
Das obligate Party-Selfie.
Gott, sehen wir alle schlimm aus!
- (Asja) Egal!
Wer seine Fans
bei der Stange halten will,
muss regelmässig Neues bieten.
Hast du schon eine Idee,
was das Nächste ist?
Der nächste Skandal?
Den habe ich mir noch nicht
überlegt, das kommt spontan.
Hab's mir noch nicht überlegt.
Du hast ja mal
einen Skandal lanciert, nicht?
Ja.
Du kamst ja in der "20 Minuten" -
magst du erzählen? Was war da?
* Die Mädchen lachen
und sprechen durcheinander .*
Ähm, ein Sexskandal.
(Gestellt) Whaaat.
- Ooh!
Oh.
- Ja.
Um seine Medienpräsenz zu erhöhen,
täuschte Younes
während eines Live-Streams Sex vor.
Tausende haben zugehört und geliked.
Im Nachhinein
musste Younes öffentlich einräumen,
dass das Ganze nur ein PR-Trick war,
um Aufmerksamkeit zu generieren.
Peinlich, dass ich es gemacht habe.
Keine Ahnung, was mit mir los war.
Ja, aber schlussendlich ...
Du stehst dazu.
Du konntest nicht wissen,
dass es so weit kommt.
Nein, in dem Moment dachte ich nur:
"Ich will fame, ich will noch mehr."
Du wirst süchtig danach,
dass die Leute über dich reden.
So einen Skandal würde ich
jetzt nicht mehr verursachen, nein.
Ja.
* Push-Ton *
* Push-Töne *
* Hysterisches Kreischen *
Younes' nächste Selbstvermarktungs-
aktion: ein Fantreffen.
Ihr Idol steht real vor ihnen.
Für die Kids ist das die grosse
Chance auf ein gemeinsames Selfie
oder sogar ein Playback-Video
für die eigene Online-Galerie.
Danke!
- Bitte.
Younes, der unterdessen
18 Jahre alt geworden ist,
präsentiert sich im neuen Look -
mit Brille
und frisch aufgespritzten Lippen.
Für den Auftritt
bekommt er zwar keine Gage,
aber einen erneuten Popularitätskick.
Sorry.
- Nein, nein, nein. Nicht weinen!
Aber jetzt
musst du lachen fürs Bild!
Ich habe kein Taschentuch. Gut?
Willst du eins machen? - Ja.
Wir machen einfach so.
- Mit dem Filter. Egal welcher.
Danke.
- Bitte. Willst auch noch so eins?
Er macht ja nur Fotos oder TikTok -
was bietet er euch denn?
Man sagt ja Promis, es sind Stars.
Und die will man ja immer sehen.
Die sieht man nicht alle paar Mi-
nuten, deswegen lohnt es sich auch.
Was kann er denn gut
oder anders als andere?
* Sie rufen durcheinander. *
Er kann tolle Bewegungen machen.
- Er ist einfach der Beste.
Und auf Fotos?
Er ist einfach schön.
- Und kann megagut bearbeiten.
Er ist einfach der Schönste.
- Und er hat einen coolen Style.
Und megaschöne Lippen.
- Ja.
Es stimmt!
Und dass die gespritzt sind?
- Das weiss ich. - Egal.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Wir lieben dich, Younes!
* Rufe *
Hast du das Gefühl,
du änderst noch mehr an dir?
Die Brüste
will ich mir machen lassen.
Wieso?
Weil ich mega kleine habe.
Also ich will nicht ...
... so überdimensionale machen
wie Kylie Jenner,
das finde ich auch nicht schön,
aber einfach normal, ein C oder so.
Denn ich habe wirklich wenig
und ja, ähm, eben. Ja.
Das ist das Einzige,
was ich momentan im Sinn habe.
Mhm. Und du denkst,
dann bist du bei dir angekommen?
Ich weiss nicht, wie mein Gesicht
in zehn Jahren aussieht,
das kann sich noch verändern,
aber momentan will ich
nichts mehr am Gesicht machen.
Ja.
Also noch den Busen
und dann ist fertig? - Ja.
* Perlende Klänge *
Massenhaft Anerkennung
und Zuneigung -
Younes
bekommt von seinen Fans heute das,
was er in seiner Kindheit vermisste.
Du bist ja jetzt 18 -
hast du schon mal überlegt,
was ist, wenn du kein Fame
und keine Fans mehr hast?
Ich habe mich auch schon gefragt,
wie's in Zukunft sein wird,
denn die Kinder werden älter ...
- Du auch.
Ihre Interessen ändern sich,
meine auch.
Aber ich habe mir
nicht gross Gedanken gemacht,
ich lasse es auf mich zukommen.
Aber wie wird es,
wenn du keine Likes mehr kriegst?
Ich weiss es auch nicht.
Das wäre scheisse.
Ich habe mir aber wirklich noch
keine Gedanken darüber gemacht.
(Alle) Younes, Younes, Younes!
* Kreischen *